Avengers end game is filled with
mind-blowing moments on a scale never
before seen in cinematic history but it
also includes a lot of small quiet
moments and hidden details including one
super important cameo most fans missed
[Music]
it happens during the support-group
scene early in the film where Steve
Rogers has shown discussing the impact
of the snap with several other survivors
one of whom is played by end game
co-director Joe Russo but while some
fans of the Marvel Cinematic Universe
were geeking out to balbirr they may not
have noticed that one or the other
support group members is none other than
legendary comic book writer and artist
jim Starlin a man who created the knows
Gomorrah and Drax in the first place
credited simply a support group man
number one stalin opened up about his
endgame cameo in a post on instagram my
film debut not a great time of some
terrific folks like Christopher Markus
and Stephen McFeely the script writers
when I wasn't busy learning my one-line
or getting made-up I had fun chatting
with them they interacted Joe Russo were
exceptionally open with me and for that
I sincerely thank them even though I had
to keep my mouth shut for a year and a
half afterwards that I can now share
these pics with you those Stalin's cameo
were small his involvement in the film
at all is a big deal considering some of
the major issues he has had with Marvel
and the recent past in January 2017 for
instance Stalin posted on Facebook that
his royalty check for his minor villain
cagey beast appearing in Batman vs
Superman was much bigger than anything
I've gotten for Thanos Gamora and drag
showing up in any of the various Marvel
movies they appeared in combined and in
December 2017 Stalin publicly parted
ways with a comic book branch of Marvel
as he felt editorial decisions had
severely undermined a long-running
Thanos project he'd been working on for
the company but it seems as though the
mutual admiration between Stalin and
brothers Joe and Anthony Russo has
smoothed over those past difficulties in
February 2017 Stalin posted on Facebook
that after seeing his Infinity Gauntlet
home and the infinity war behind the
scenes shorts he was excited to see what
the directors might do with the material
adding Anthony and Joe I'm ready for my
close-up anytime you are to which the
Russo is replied
we've got your close-up ready mr. Stalin
it's almost as if appearing in a movie
with his most popular creation with
Stalin's destiny
read it run from it
destiny arrives all the same and now
it's here
those Stalin didn't appear in Avengers
infinity war he told his Facebook fans
that he was proud of the movie and he
told sci-fi that he was particularly
happy with Avengers endgame I was very
pleased there are a lot of possibilities
and I thought they did a good job the
way they did it was quite satisfying I
love the movie I thought it was better
than infinity war actually it's much
more spectacular and much more of an
emotional rollercoaster and that's
saying something on the latter part
especially after Comoros demise he also
doesn't think that we've seen the last
of Thanos regardless of how endgame
concluded I don't see Marvel letting up
because it's basically printing money
for them there's a whole universe of
stuff they haven't even touched yet I
have faith that somewhere down the line
that that fans will return because he's
basically the Darth Vader of this
particular decade he's become a pop
culture icon so there you have it folks
the one tiny cameo in Avengers endgame
has slipped right under your radar a
serious ties to Marvel and if Stalin has
any sway in the decision-making process
Thanos might return from space dust for
another Marvel movie let's hope if that
happens the heroes know to aim for his
head at the first time around check out
one of our newest videos right here plus
even more loop of videos about Avengers
endgame are coming soon subscribe to our
YouTube channel and hit the bell so you
don't miss a single one
[Music]